(souffle du vent)
- 1964 : le cinéaste québécois
Gilles Groulx sort son film
"Le chat dans le sac".
♪ (jazz) ♪
L'histoire d'une rupture
amoureuse, dans le style
nouvelle vague française,
avec une trame sonore composée
par nul autre que John Coltrane.
♪ (jazz) ♪
Le réalisateur, fan de jazz,
est allé en personne rencontrer
le grand saxophoniste dans
un studio du New Jersey.
Il en est reparti
avec un enregistrement de
37 minutes, un enregistrement
inédit jusqu'ici.
FRÉDÉRIC SAVARD, agent de ventes
directes internationales, ONF
- La session a été enregistrée
sur une période très brève
aussi. John Coltrane n'avait pas
beaucoup de temps à accorder
pour ce type d'enregistrement,
donc ça a eu lieu entre 14 h
et 17 h le 24 juin, donc c'est
tout. Et Gilles Groulx est parti
ensuite avec l'enregistrement,
donc la bande maîtresse
de cet enregistrement-là,
qui a atterri dans les archives
de l'ONF, qui y est resté
pendant plus de 55 ans.
- C'est grâce à cet employé
de l'Office national du film
du Canada, Frédéric Savard,
que cet enregistrement peut
maintenant sortir en disque.
Il a fallu cinq ans de
négociations avec les héritiers
du musicien et Impulse Records,
qui détient son catalogue, pour
que les bandes, découvertes
au début des années 2000,
puissent légalement être
rendues publiques.
- Comme j'ai vu que certaines
personnes prétendaient en ligne
que les enregistrements avaient
disparu alors que c'était tout
à fait faux, c'est devenu un peu
une mission pour moi de faire
en sorte qu'on puisse libérer
ces enregistrements des voûtes
de l'ONF pour qu'ils soient
entendus partout dans le monde
et pour que la vision de Gilles
Groulx soit reconnue parce que,
pour moi, c'est quand même assez
significatif qu'un Québécois,
en 64, ait réussi à convaincre
un jazzman de la trempe
de John Coltrane à faire
une trame sonore pour son film.
♪ (jazz) ♪
- La rencontre entre les deux
hommes reste très mystérieuse.
Ont-ils développé une amitié,
une complicité intellectuelle?
Coltrane a-t-il aussi été attiré
par l'appât du gain facile?
♪ (jazz) ♪
Les 37 minutes de musique
enregistrées ce 24 juin 1964
ont été payées cash et ne sont
pas une composition originale
du musicien.
STANLEY PÉAN,
animateur, ICI Musique
- Cette musique-là, ce sont
cinq thèmes qu'on connaissait
déjà, qu'il avait déjà
enregistrés. Il réimprovise
sur des thèmes qu'on connaît,
"Like Sonny", "Village Blues",
"Naima", "Out of this World"...
Et donc, c'est une...
une note en bas de page
de l'oeuvre de John Coltrane,
mais c'est une note en bas
de page fort intéressante.
♪ (jazz) ♪
- Un enregistrement
qui peut donc maintenant
être ajouté à la discographie
du légendaire saxophoniste.
Ici Catherine François,